Mark: I'm really proud of you guys.
*ominous piano music begins*
We killed it at PAX this year.
And now we get to go home.
And we get to see our families again.
We get to...see Chica again.
(News report: ...may result in downed trees and scattered power outages.)
Ethan: You're all I got left.
*talks to the  microwavable pizza box
M: Can we brave it? Maybe the flights not cancelled?
Tyler: It-It's cancelled.
M: What are we going to eat? We only got bagel bites.
E: I ate 'em all last night...I was hungry!
M: You bastard! E: No! T: No, you'll kill him! *Everyone screaming*
Listen...there's no birds,
There's no animals...there's NOTHING.
Amy: Kathryn, It's not...It's not like this is the first time this has happened.
I mean- I mean it could be worse...right?
E: *screams* Everyone's already dead!(News report in background)
Mark & Ethan: NO...NO...NO!
Mark: You put em down!
M: Chica...I'll be with you ok.
E: Something's wrong with Mark...he's letting snow in!
M: I found more food.
If it's good enough for Chica...it's good enough for us.
Isn't that right?
Ethan: No!..Stop.
Kathryn: Noo!.. Nope.
K: Ugh.
M: You need to embrace the cold...Embrace it! *ominous music stops)
Kathryn: Nope.
Mark: It's destiny!
E: Mark, we don't have to embrace the cold.
Kathryn: Nope.
Mark: Embrace it!
Ethan: You could put on clothes.
Kathryn: Yeah
Mark: Embrace it!
E: Like a normal person.
M: EMBRACE IT!
Ethan: Mark!
Kathryn: Nope.
K: He wants to go out! We don't want him in here! Let him go out! *ominous music restarts*
T: I don't know what to do.
K: Just let him go out! Just let him go- he wants to go out?
Let him go out...HE'S NOT WEARING CLOTHES!
♪ Let it go- ♪
*dramatic chord*
M: *Demonic Voice* Hey guys!
*video ends*